los óxidos tienen mucha fuerza de anillo
o tensión angular y esto los hace muy
reactivos a la apertura de anillo en
este vídeo
veremos reacciones de apertura de anillo
de epoxi 2 usando núcleos filos fuertes
en el primer paso añadimos un núcleo
filo fuerte a nuestro óxido y en el
segundo paso añadimos una fuente de
protones y el núcleo filo va a terminar
por abrir el anillo y le va a añadir en
una adición anti él
o h que se crea en términos de región
química el núcleo fino añade al carbono
sustituido va a añadir a este carbono de
aquí
si retrocedemos y vemos al epp óxido de
la izquierda
es este carbono y este carbono está
unido a otros 2 carbonos por lo que
sería clasificado como un carbono
secundario
mientras que el carbono del lado derecho
está unido a otros 3 carbonos por lo que
es un carbono terciario
el mecanismo para esta reacción es un
mecanismo tipo sn 2 lo que significa que
nuestro núcleo filo fuerte va a atacar
al carbono con menor impedimento
estético que es el de la izquierda ya
que un hidrógeno ocupa menos espacio que
un voluminoso grupo r de la derecha y
esa es la región química de aquí la
estéreo química es una apertura anti del
anillo para una visión anti del núcleo
filo y esto afectará a posibles centros
quirales como veremos en otros ejemplos
veamos ejemplos de núcleo filos fuertes
para tu núcleo fino fuerte puedes usar
un año- nalco óxido algo como este de
aquí puedes usar un reactivo de griñán
que sabemos es una fuente de carbón
iones podemos tener un carbono con carga
negativa de esta manera y no tendrías
que escribir tu reactivo de griñán así
puedes escribirlo sólo como r
m
ve
el libro por sí mismo no es un núcleo
filo fuerte pero si él y duro proviene
de algo como y duro de litio y aluminio
funciona como un núcleo filo fuerte
entonces podemos mostrar como ese y duro
realmente viene de un y duro del litio
y aluminio entonces si dibujamos esto
aquí
el aluminio va a tener una carga formal
de menos 1
y el litio tendría una carga formal de
más 1
entonces el duro del litio y aluminio es
fuente de un núcleo filo fuerte es sólo
que el y duro por sí mismo como ya
dijimos no es el mejor núcleo filo y
luego por supuesto podrías tener algo
como añón de sulfuro de hidrógeno o
elaño y dos sulfuro de aquí que también
funciona como un núcleo filo fuerte
echemos un vistazo al mecanismo para
formar para formar alcoholes vamos a
nuevamente comenzar con nuestro stock
sido usar el mismo epoxi lo que usamos
antes o sea que va a haber una erre
prima aquí
r doble prima alejándose de nosotros y
un hidrógeno saliendo hacia nosotros y
un grupo r alejándose de nosotros así
cuando pienso en las diferencias de
electro negatividad sé que el oxígeno es
más electro negativo que este carbono
por ejemplo entonces el oxígeno va a
jalar estos electrones en los enlaces
entre el oxígeno y el carbono más cerca
del oxígeno
dándole una carga parcial negativa
a traer algo de densidad electrónica
lejos de este carbono le dará a este
carbono de aquí una carga parcial
positiva y por tanto ese carbono va a
funcionar como nuestro electro filo
cuando el núcleo filo venga el núcleo
filo va a tener un par de electrones
disponibles y una carga formal de menos
tiene dos opciones puede atacar al
carbono de la izquierda o puede atacar
al carbono de la derecha
y dado que es un núcleo filo fuerte que
lleva a cabo un mecanismo tipo sn 2 va a
atacar al carbono de la izquierda
nuevamente el carbono de la izquierda
tiene menor impedimento estético ese
hidrógeno no es grande comparado con
algún grupo alquiló del lado derecho
entonces el núcleo filo va a atacar al
electro filo así
y cuando eso sucede va a mandar estos
dos electrones de aquí hacia el oxígeno
podemos dibujar ahora el producto de ese
ataque en núcleo físico ahora hemos
hemos roto el anillo tóxico y tenemos un
par extra de electrones disponibles en
ese oxígeno dándole al oxígeno una carga
formal de menos 1
estos grupos r en el carbono de la
derecha no han cambiado siguen estando
ahí
y hemos añadido nuestro núcleo filo
así iba a empujar al hidrógeno hacia
arriba
con respecto al plano y luego tenemos un
grupo r de este lado así
entonces el núcleo filo tiene que atacar
desde abajo porque el oxígeno está
arriba y el núcleo filo va a atacar al
carbono que tenga menor impedimento
estético esto termina poniendo al núcleo
filo y al oxígeno en posición anti con
respecto al otro
en el segundo paso podemos añadir una
fuente de protones algo como agua y
vamos a obtener una reacción ácido base
en la que nuestro alcock sido va a tomar
un protón del agua lo que lleva a estos
electrones de aquí hacia el oxígeno
y eso formará nuestro producto final con
un alcohol
voy a tener un alcohol de este lado
y nuevamente mis grupos r siguen estando
ahí tengo r prima y r doble prima
nuestro núcleo filo está unido y el
hidrógeno es empujado hacia arriba y
nuestro grupo r sigue ahí atrás ese es
el mecanismo para la reacción tipo s n 2
hagamos hagamos un problema que
involucre stereo química para que
podamos ver cómo el mecanismo
determinará la estéreo química de los
productos voy a comenzar y pondré en mi
xbox ido saliendo hacia mí del plano así
y luego en este carbono de arriba voy a
tener un grupo metilo alejándose de mí
en el espacio
este es mi reactivo y voy a usar el
óxido de sodio
voy a dibujar al óxido de sodio aquí y
usaremos etanol como solvente tenemos al
etanol aquí como nuestro solvente
así
si vemos a este óxido es un poco difícil
ver la exterior química vamos a volver a
dibujar esta molécula y la veremos desde
un ángulo distinto
si veo a ese óxido desde un ángulo
diferente lo estoy viendo por encima y
abajo un poco y eso pondría a mi stock
sigue yendo hacia arriba así
y luego este carbono de aquí que va a
tener al grupo metilo hacia abajo
relativo al plano del anillo y luego
este carbono de la izquierda tiene un
interés que no entonces el primer paso
sería identificar al núcleo si lo que
por supuesto es el año tóxico puedo
dibujar el unión óxido aquí
y después necesito pensar en dónde
atacará el núcleo filo yo sé que este
oxígeno de arriba siendo más electro
negativo que los carbonos va a tener una
carga parcial negativa
y entonces tengo dos opciones puede ser
el carbono de la izquierda o puede ser
el carbono de la derecha y si pienso en
el hecho de que este es un núcleo filo
fuerte mecanismo tipo sn 2 va a atacar
al carbono con menor impedimento
estético que por supuesto es el carbono
de la izquierda que va a tener una carga
parcial positiva y entonces vamos a
tener un ataque núcleo físico mi núcleo
si lo va a atacar a este carbono de aquí
lo que mandará a estos electrones de
aquí hacia el oxígeno
voy a dibujar el producto de eso
tengo mi anillo
tengo mi anillo así y abría el anillo
epóxico por lo que ahora este enlace va
unido a un oxígeno y tiene
pares de electrones disponibles lo que
le da una carga formal de menos 1
sigue habiendo un grupo metilo saliendo
por debajo de este carbono y añadido mi
núcleo filo a este carbono voy a dibujar
a mi oxígeno y luego un estilo así y
luego empuje al hidrógeno hacia arriba
entonces cuando esta reacción ocurrió el
nitrógeno que estaba abajo relativo al
plano del anillo se fue hacia arriba por
lo que ahora hay un hidrógeno hacia
arriba de este carbono y en el paso
final voy a protón ar el alcohol sido
con un par de electrones disponibles
tomarán un protón del etanol lo que
mandará a estos electrones hacia acá
informó mi alcohol como producto cuando
dibujo mi producto de este lado tengo
ahora
o h y sigo teniendo un grupo metilo
hacia abajo y de este lado tengo un
oxígeno y un estilo así
si quisiera dibujar mi producto como una
estructura bidimensional puedo ver puedo
ver hacia acá puedo verlo desde arriba y
dibujar lo que veo cuando lo miro desde
arriba
entonces puedo dibujar mi anillo aquí
está el anillo y si observo a este
carbono de aquí hay un bache saliendo
hacia mí y entonces puedo representar a
lo h saliendo hacia mí con
cunha
actúa
y hay un grupo metilo alejándose de mí
en este carbono
este grupo metilo se está alejando de mí
entonces voy a dibujar unos guiones para
ese grupo metilo
y cuando veo al otro carbono aquí tengo
un
estilo alejándose de mí aquí pondría
unos guiones alejándose de mí así
esta por supuesto
esta porción de la molécula
y este es mi producto cuando veo a lo
que ocurrió con la estéreo química
comencemos con el carbono de arriba este
carbono superior tenía un grupo metilo
alejándose y un oxígeno saliendo hacia
mí en ese carbono y si vemos de este
lado eso es lo mismo que tenemos tenemos
un grupo metilo alejándose de nosotros y
luego un oxígeno saliendo hacia nosotros
así entonces es la misma configuración
absoluta en ese carbono si vemos al loto
carbono si vemos a este carbono de abajo
del lado izquierdo
tenemos un oxígeno saliendo hacia
nosotros y del lado derecho en este
carbono
ahora el oxígeno se aleja de nosotros en
el espacio y así vemos una inversión en
la configuración
justo aquí tenemos una inversión en la
configuración en términos de estéreo
química pasamos de una cuña a unos iones
y eso por supuesto se debe al mecanismo
tuvimos un ataque núcleo físico en este
centro quiral y por lo tanto observamos
una inversión en la configuración en ese
centro que irán
hagamos un ejemplo más de un núcleo filo
fuerte atacando un óxido
y esta vez usaremos un reactivo de
griñán
voy a comenzar con bromuro de fenil
magnesio ya hicimos del bromuro
en el magnesio nuestro reactivo de
griñán
en el primer paso vamos a añadir óxido
de etileno
el epoxi lo más simple en el segundo
paso vamos a añadir
y un libro neo h
o más
y eso será nuestra fuente de protones
pero debe de ser en el segundo paso no
se debe de añadir al mismo tiempo porque
habría una reacción ha sido base del
reactivo de green hart con los iones y
drones
entonces si veo al bromuro de fenil
magnesio lo puedo dibujar aquí o puedo
dibujarlo nuevamente para identificar a
mi carbunión
si pienso en lo que va a ocurrir
los electrones en el enlace entre este
carbono y el magnesio el carbono es más
electro negativo que el magnesio por lo
que pueden pensar que estos dos
electrones están en ese carbono así lo
que daría a ese carbono una carga formal
de menos 1
y ahora tenemos un carbón y tenemos
d
r más
así y eso será el núcleo filo cuando
tenemos cuando tenemos nuestro óxido de
etileno
que también viene es la misma idea el
oxígeno es más electro negativo entonces
carga parcial negativa en el oxígeno y
carga parcial positiva en los carbonos
que son simétricos entonces cuando
pienso en un ataque núcleo físico estos
electrones en azul van a ser mi núcleos
y lo van a atacar a mi electro filo
mandando a estos electrones hacia arriba
y cuando dibujo el producto
del ataque núcleo físico tengo mi anillo
aquí
y ahora voy a terminar con un al cocido
que se ve así
voy a resaltar los electrones en azul
los electrones en azul formaron un nuevo
enlace un enlace carbono carbono aquí
enlace carbono carbono y es por eso que
los órganos metálicos son tan útiles
puedes formar estos enlaces
carbono-carbono
y luego puedo ver que los dos carbonos
del lado derecho este carbono y este
carbono esos son los que provienen del
óxido de etileno muy bien entonces en el
último paso es una reacción ácido base y
este al óxido va a tomar un protón del h
3 o más en el segundo paso
de electrones disponibles toman un
protón
manda a estos electrones al oxígeno
y puedes dibujar el producto
una vez más aquí está mi anillo
y ya protones me al cocido
para formar un alcohol
y el nombre de este alcohol si pienso en
si pienso en que este es el carbono 1 y
este es el carbono 2 tengo un grupo
senil unido a ese etanol entonces 2
fenil etanol sería el nombre del
producto formado
el 2 fenil etanol es famoso por ser un
componente del aceite de rosas esta
molécula huele como a rosas y se utiliza
mucho en la industria del perfume esta
es una manera de hacer dos fenil etanol
hay muchas maneras de hacerlo pero
considero que la química del perfume es
muy interesante